uh
this session uh the first speaker
is
that
um so yeah i'm looking forward to
spending the next two years as a postdoc
here at berkeley um today i want to tell
you about some of the things i've been
thinking about over the last few years
um regarding what algorithic insights
from tcs can tell us about modern
challenges in data science now this
turns out to be a fairly subtle endeavor
because of a fundamental disconnect
between the way we traditionally reason
about algorithm design and the kinds of
problems that arise in data science
applications let's take something like
max flow you know the gold standard
we're taught is that we should have an
algorithm that if you fed it in
arbitrary worst case instance correctly
spits out a max flow after running a
polynomial amount of time and by now we
have a fairly mature understanding of
which problems on this map you can hope
to achieve this gold standard
for instance sat solving or craft
coloring uh sorry um and which questions
for instance that solving your graph
coloring for which is likely to be
impossible
you can draw a similar looking map for
problems in data science
but actually through this traditional
lens of worst case analysis a more
accurate depiction would be something
like this
and the reason is that most
ml problems if posed from this worst
case perspective are just hopelessly
hard
so to get actionable theory for machine
learning it's not enough to just develop
the right algorithmic primitives you
really need the right mathematical
models to go along with them
this begs two questions which have been
the focus of my work first have we
converged to the right toolbox for
dealing with fundamental problems in
data science and two are we looking at
the right models in this talk i want to
tell you about some natural settings
where new techniques are provably
necessary
as well as instances where working with
the right or wrong model can have
consequences far beyond the real world
theory
the course of advancing this viewpoint
my research has touched upon most of the
regions on this map but in the interest
of time i want to hone in on my work in
one particular area namely the design of
algorithms that are robust to a number
of any number of real-world deviations
in your data
okay so to unpack what i mean by
robustness let's talk about some of the
common challenges that arise in working
with modern datasets
so it's a fact of life that modern data
can be extremely high dimensional
it can be very heavy-tailed for instance
if you plot how often different
categories of objects appear in standard
scene recognition benchmarks you'll find
many categories with a very small number
of occurrences
when it comes to things like online
reinforcement learning data can be
generated in a dynamic non-iid fashion
that may even depend on the actions you
choose
and data could be misspecified in the
sense that there's a disconnect between
the setting where you know that your
email system works the spec
and the setting where you want to
actually want to deploy it
so for instance your spec could be some
great theorem you proved about learning
over linearly separable data and reality
could be that the data set in the wild
that you want to apply your algorithm to
simply doesn't satisfy this assumption
spec could be the traditional antenna
supervised learning pipeline and reality
could be that there's an adversary
that's able to tamper with some fraction
of your data for instance in the context
of a data poisoning attack
now my work is focused on designing new
algorithms for basic learning problems
to meet these kinds of challenges and
for the sake of concreteness i want to
tell you about one very recent result of
ours joined with fred kohler ankur
moytra and
that seeks to address all four of these
challenges simultaneously
so let me just tell you sort of one
nugget from this paper
just consider the standard you know
setting of linear regression
but with the following twist let's
imagine that a random but constant
fraction of the data has been
arbitrarily corrupted
okay so just to recall
the standard linear regression setup we
get x y pairs where the y's are noisy
linear functions of the x's
where the linear function is
parametrized by some vector w
let's adopt some standard scalings so
let's say that the x's are you know
normalized have unit norm and w has norm
at most r where you should think of r as
like the dynamic range of the problem
and we can imagine the noise is maybe
coming from a gaussian with variance
sigma squared and here we should think
of sigma as being significantly smaller
than r
okay so this is just standard you know
fixed design and regression
now let's imagine an adversary comes
along and is able to tamper with a
randomly chosen 10 percent of your data
so in particular this adversary you can
imagine as being all powerful it
inspects you know it has access to the
full data set
and can run in as much time as you want
and eventually they're going to
they're going to change these y values
to whatever they want
and we as the learner only observe xy
pairs
okay so what's our objective here our
objective is to compete with the
all-powerful baseline which actually
knew exactly which points were corrupted
because if you knew which points were
corrupted you could of course just throw
them out of the data set and run
ordinarily squares on the rest of the
data
and the objective we want to minimize is
what we'll call the clean mean squared
error
roughly speaking this is the average
squared distance between your prediction
which is w hat inner product x
and the ground truth label without noise
w inner product x
let me emphasize that while there have
been a number of exciting recent works
on robust statistics and high dimensions
the model that i've just described is
sort of a departure from these works in
the sense that we're not making any
kinds of strong assumptions on the
process that actually generates the xis
in particular not only could they you
know be iid from some arbitrary
distribution these xi's could actually
arrive in some adaptive fashion
okay so what do we show
so one result from this paper shows that
for any value of corruption
from zero to a half
we give an efficient algorithm for the
supercontaminated regression problem
that achieves clean mean squared error
which is essentially optimal um up the
law factors
and because our algorithm is able to
tolerate
adaptively chosen covariates
we're actually able to get extensions to
challenging online problems for instance
we get the first algorithm for linear
contextual bandits that's able to handle
a constant fraction of uh the time spent
time steps being corrupted and the
regret that we achieve in this context
is also optimal to log factors
to complement these results we also show
that you can't actually achieve these
kinds of guarantees using off-the-shelf
techniques like grading descent to
minimize the convex loss for instance
minimizing the l1 loss or hebrew loss
and so at this juncture let me tell you
a bit about the algorithm
the nice thing is that the analysis is a
bit tricky but the algorithm itself is
very simple to state
so we're going to minimize this notion
of squared error
over
vectors w hat
and simultaneously over subsets of the
data set so here you should think of the
subset s as our guess for which points
in the data set have been have not been
corrupted
and this s where in the optimization is
going to range over
some family of large subsets of the data
which behave quasi randomly and uh the
technical details aren't um
uh having to talk about offline but the
algorithm you know once we have this in
place is quite simple so we initialize
our guess for which points aren't
corrupted to be all points
and then we just repeat the following
i keep s fixed and i refit w hat
then i keep w hat fixed and i refit s
okay so you can think of this as just
some kind of alternating minimization
procedure
and the point is that after you run this
for enough steps you converge to an
approximate stationary point for this
objective
and the key structural result which is
proof i won't tell you about is that an
approximate stationary point for this
problem suffices to achieve this near
optimal clean mean squared error
guarantee
okay in the remaining time let me tell
you about one experiment in a related
setting um on real world data
so in a different paper with the same
set of authors we explored sort of the
analogous setting for classification so
here the y values
are binary labels instead of real valued
okay and for instance this uh
the model that we considered uh captures
learning half spaces with bisar noise
the algorithm that we consider turns out
on the surface to be
quite similar it's also based on some
kind of iterative re-weighing of the
data steps to mitigate the effect of
corruptions
let me just tell you about the
experiment so we we ran our algorithm on
the uci adult data sets here the task is
given the demographic info for an
individual tell whether they make more
than 50k
and we injected into this data set a
particular attack the details aren't
super important but suffice it to say
that we're targeting a specific
sub-population of the data and so you
can think of it as injecting noise but
in a heterogeneous fashion into the data
set
okay so what happens if you train on
this noisy data
so we compare it against three different
baselines random forest logistic
regression and minimizing a particular
context loss
and as you vary the noise rate on the
x-axis
and look at the resulting you know
classifier that you get out of these
algorithms you'll notice that they do
fairly similarly
if you measure the accuracy over the
entire population
but if you restrict your attention to
for instance uh people in the target
group who do make more than 50k then you
see a significant degradation in the
performance of classifiers obtained by
logistic regression and this context
loss
as the noise rate increases okay
in fact this phenomena is quite robust
across different kinds of subpopulations
and
you know this is just some empirical
observation but it suggests that perhaps
being robust in richer noise models
isn't just some kind of mathematical
exercise it really helps guide the
design of better algorithms downstream
okay so in the meaning time let me just
briefly mention some other things i've
worked on so it turns out this general
blueprint of
iterative re-weighing schemes has also
been useful in my work on secure
distributed learning and even in more
traditional learning theory settings
where you actually assume the data might
come from some nice distribution like a
gaussian and you're trying to learn some
complex function class like neural
networks
here the idea of carefully re-weighing
the data turns out to be useful even in
these non-robust settings for instance
yielding the first example of a neural
network class that you can learn
efficiently but provably not by noisy
grading scent on a student network for
instance
i've also worked on mixture models this
is like a stylized model for
heterogeneous data
so i've worked on a sort of
heterogeneous variance of robust linear
aggression
a latent variable model called mixtures
of product distributions
and turns out related ideas for learning
mixture models have also been useful for
settling some old debates in the natural
sciences so in classical optics for
instance by rephrasing the problem with
optical resolution as a mixture model
learning problem we were actually able
to refute the long-standing belief that
half the wavelength of light marks the
point at which optical resolution
becomes impossible for classical systems
among other inverse problems in the
sciences i've also worked on quantum
learning where even the sample
complexity for various basic learning
tasks remain open
here it turns out that tools from
showing lower bounds for online decision
making actually are perfect fit for
showing separations for learning with
and without quantum memory for a variety
of tasks like shadow tomography state
certification etc
and more broadly you know i'm interested
in tcs as a whole and i've spent some
time also thinking about algorithms for
counting and sampling
um you know here are some questions that
i'm very excited to think about over the
next two years if any of these piqued
your interest please do reach out it
would be great to collaborate
um why do you think random firsts do so
well
yeah yeah i always get this good yeah so
um
so for a bit of context i guess the one
baseline
like theory baseline that we're trying
to sort of um
improve on was this improper learner of
um
dear clinical us at all um and you know
even though the algorithm is quite
different from random force you can kind
of think of both as trying to find some
partition of space and sort of uh
classifiers that do well over these
different parts of the partition
so in some sense we're trying to get
some kind of simple classifier that is
able to match this baseline and it
stands to reason that maybe like
algorithms that partition up the space
in different ways might be able to
mitigate this
this kind of
violation of quality of opportunities
great questions
[Applause]